but here's my problem with real estate
you don't just yeah like the person was
like yeah I'm just gonna you know get
into real estate and I'm just become a
millionaire I've always share that yeah
I'm just yeah how'd you make Oh Real
Estate it's like I have people that have
good friends okay I know we're becoming
friends now but I don't know you that
well and I know you've done very well I
have very good friends that have killed
it in real estate killed it
but they've been doing it for 15 20
years they've built a skill set they've
built a skill set okay so this whole you
know this get rich quick mentality this
nft mentality oh I'm gonna buy Dogecoin
it goes to the moon mentality I'm sorry
bro it doesn't work for Real Estate so
that's the biggest problem I have with
real estate yes you can build wealth
with real estate yes you can make a ton
of money with real estate yes and it's
an amazing career but most people aren't
willing to put in the work to do that so
the whole like yeah I do real estate and
I just become a millionaire that concept
yeah it doesn't work that way you we
can't keep comparing real estate to
stocks real estate to crypto it's not
the same animal like almost I call them
button pushing Investments like you want
to buy stocks you want to buy crypto you
just push the button on the computer you
get it boom and it pretty much works one
way you buy low you sell High yeah
buying and holding just puts the odds in
your favor it's more likely to sell High
later but it's a very simple
one-dimensional way fully agree real
estate is like seven dimensions yes
right that's another thing people don't
talk about is how many different Realms
it goes in 100 yeah you're talking about
residential right now in this case I'm
talking about residents the principles
will work no matter which class you get
into it is work there's elbow grease
that goes into yes you get more freedom
for instance I can't go buy a stock at
less than market value I can't find a
purchase like I really got to dump this
Apple stock I don't know what to do can
will you take it for 50 cents so
foreclosure or stuff like that real
estate will open opportunities like that
I can't make Apple worth more if I
bought Apple stock well in real estate
there's things I can do to add the value
that is the benefit of it the downside
is it is work yes it is absolutely work
and it will take time away from the
other things you're doing if you're
working correct like so a lot of people
like doctors dentists people with a very
high income they could lose money
investing in real estate because the
time they got to put in to make that
investment work yes takes away from
where they're at so part of it is like
knowing where are you in life if you're
this young 24 year old house hacking
like we talked about yes this is a
no-brainer for you you're gonna pay rent
anywhere you might as well do it with
your buddies learn it learn the rhythm
of being a landlord learn how the laws
work learn what worked and what didn't
work and kind of build it that way but a
hundred percent I'd never stop saying
this real estate is a get rich slow
scheme dude you have no idea how much I
appreciate you saying that because you
talked about the beginning of why your
firm became so successful you talked
about having integrity and and not bsing
and not going for a quick Buck I forgot
what words you use exactly but that was
sort of the the concept of it and and
that's the biggest
thing that I like I see how much work it
takes to get good at real estate
from the the searching the properties on
the MLS finding it buying the you know
buying low fixing it up hiring the
general contractor all right caught in
the grass finding the plumber doing this
doing that
and and it would be a disservice to not
congratulate the amount of work that you
put in because it's not easy and that's
a and that's essentially what I coming
back to my point is like I didn't want
to dedicate that time I said I want to
crush it in my financial job okay and
then on the side I'm doing shows and
then on the side of that I'm going out
and trying to have fun in life and
there's only so many hours in a day you
have no idea with how many people are
like Adam you've got ton of money in the
bank you've got connections why don't
you get more involved in real estate I'm
like I value my time I want to it's not
about me making a couple extra hundred
grand right now in my life right it's
about I just want to enjoy life but it
it is a career it's not a if you're
gonna side Hustle real estate
that's a very get rich slow situation
very what if you're just an investor
it's still more work that's what we're
talking about
because we kind of brought up Selling
Houses as an agent versus owning them
they are completely different yeah
worlds but even but at the same the same
principle whether if you're real estate
and you're talking about being a real
estate agent real estate broker okay
you're not like
the 80 20 Pareto Principle the top 20 of
realtors make 80 of the money right and
they're working their freaking ass off
you know this okay because you're in the
top 20 you're not just lollygagging and
I know I just made another 10 million
dollars no it doesn't work that way but
as far as the real estate investor goes
that's that's equally as much work
scouting the property and everything you
talked about with the Burr method and
whether you're going to do um
um
you talk about long-distance investing
house hacking all this is not easy stuff
it's nothing like the button push
Investments correct it's not reading a
Blog article oh this crypto is supposed
to do whatever I'm gonna buy it and see
what happens it is a completely
different world the people that tend to
lose money in real estate are the people
that brought that attitude it's like
stocks and they try to put it into this
world that's the worst thing you would
be better off to not invest in real
estate if that's what you're gonna do so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]